-Exchange-
The Exchange is a place where you can post requests, asking members and tutors for various services including translation, writing correction, pronunciation correction and more.
Choose the type of request you would like to make then click Post. Each time a response is posted to your request, by a member, you will receive a notification. You will be able to decide how many points you want to award and to whom.
Should you be interested, you can earn points by responding to requests from other members on the Exchange.
-Profile-
Your profile shows your learning activities and statistics, your description and your activity feed. Communicate with other members by posting on their walls. You can edit your profile information on the Settings page.
-LingQ Avatar-
Your Avatar is a graphical representation of your progress in your new language. Earn Avatar credits when you create LingQs. Click on your Avatar to go to the Avatar Store to purchase artifacts with your avatar credits.
-Speak-
On the Speak page you will find a list of tutors who offer conversations in your target language. Tutors can post 1 on 1 conversations or group conversations.
You can also find tutors through the Find a Tutor page. You can request specific conversation times.
Discussions on LingQ take place through Skype, and you will receive a detailed conversation report after every conversation.
-Tutoring-
To tutor, go to the Teach page to learn about how to do this. You will post discussion times in your time zone. Other members will see these in their time zone. You will receive a notification when someone signs up.
As a conversation host, you are required to fill out a Conversation Report with corrections, suggestions and comments. After your conversation, you must submit this report to the learner in order to receive your points.